gucci westman
there is no one more renowned and
talented in the beauty world i'm talking
like you did every vogue cover for years
in a row like every single issue
i i mean that's crazy i can't yeah that
was wild and i
that was a yeah a crazy time and
you now have your incredible company
westman atelier
and your packaging is so luxe these are
so amazing and listen we could all use a
little makeup
lesson every now and then i was watching
until late at night
your uh recent tutorial where you come
out in your bathroom and you show up
a little like you know you know i mean
you're the most beautiful woman ever but
you show up like very real
you've got some redness you've got a
little puff you're like i'm just i'm
having
i'm having that kind of morning and what
you do in six minutes
it's insane and i have to say watching
that tutorial i felt like
i can do this so i love that a star
makeup artist can
help anyone see that they can do it too
and one viewer
really wants your help actually and her
name is collette and she's here
thank you collette tell us about your
makeup dilemma
so thank you for having me i
just um i just turned 51. so i
i know how to apply mascara and i do
add a little lip gloss in the morning
but that's it i really never learned how
to
apply makeup so please help me well
you have the best in the business and uh
gucci is going to help you achieve the
ultimate natural summertime glow
and uh she's here so what are the tips
okay so chad first off colette i'm going
to start with our vital skin foundation
just
evening out any redness so i always have
this approach of
mixing two shades of foundation so that
way
you maintain the integrity of your
natural skin we have so many tones in
our skin
and it really is just to quickly correct
those areas
where you need a little extra i want her
skin looks nice not like oh her
foundation looks nice
i like that differentiation it's not the
foundation looks nice it's the skin look
yeah it's the skin and i really am super
into this word skinnimalism
you know it just makes me feel like you
don't need
so much stuff we don't need to use a
million things
we need to use the things that are
effective and that will make us
feel more confident and i have like you
know it's all about multitasking and
using products like how you really use
them
and that's you know driving me through
this powder because i watched you doing
it on the tutorial last night
take me through that so i have this
approach that i like to i always
envision how do children look in the
summer time
when they are bronzy and they just look
well so i always use kind of the bronzer
in a horizontal fashion under the eyes
on top of the eyes
the forehead i never go really below the
cheekbone too far because then again it
becomes
too much the same tone it's all about
kind of correcting the tone where you
don't want it
adding color back in where you do want
it and
and then you know just thinking how do
kids look where do they get sun
they get sun like here more here and it
looks so
gorgeous and not made up i'm going to
say something else
which is when you are with the top hair
colorists
in the world those colorists always talk
about
children's hair yeah because they get
these natural highlights that you lose
as an adult so the fact that you're
talking about children's skin yeah
is so revolutionary to me gucci so now
i'm adding super loaded tinted highlight
which is a really
nice warm it's a warming
kind of radiant highlight so it gives
you
definition it gives you warmth and it
gives you luminosity which
i kind of feel like it's the closer like
when you don't have a lot of time and
you feel like oh there's just a
one more thing i could use this gives
you that because it's easy to use
i created the brush the blender brush
that goes
with it and it's packed with active
ingredients that's why we called it
super loaded
so now i'm going to add a little bit
because colette mentioned um
that you you know you want to understand
what to do
in your under eye area so one tip is you
can add
this is our new highlighter it's called
nectar and
lit up and you can add it really
anywhere you naturally would like to
catch extra
light so it's all about kind of like oh
where do i want more
glow and then i'm going to give you a
pop of a cheek because we need to add
the color back in i think i might even
go with pop it which is
looks super bright and there's so many
different
things that you can do with blush and it
depends on
you know the area of application and now
i'm going for like a summer like you
look super
well rested and you're doing a lot of
yoga and meditation and oxygen
inhalation and all those things and then
this is our
um face trace and it's a contour
you know to give yourself a little bit
of definition on your eye socket
um you did gwyneth paltrow for her
wedding right i did so now i'm going to
add our newest launch which is a lip
treatment it's called squeaky clean
liquid lip balm and this color is called
pipsqueak
and it treats your lips it's packed with
jojoba oil
argan oil all of these really nice oils
just
that will nurture and hydrate your lips
and it feels really nice and
pillowy and and then you can just use
your lips around and
so collect do you like that i mean it's
like still looks like you
and perfect holy cow
that's why you're gucci westman man darn
it drop
the mic all right colette what do you
think most importantly i
i just love how natural it looks and
i just feel like i could maybe follow
those steps i mean
because it wasn't yeah just step by step
and it's just like you literally
you don't need that much time and it's
just like intuition
do you mind if i um share that six
minute video that i just watched last
night on our website
no of course not okay because it really
shows how intuitive this is and what
gucci does with her own hands and her
own products and it's like
a little mini master class and how
attainable this is
colette i thank you so much thank you
you are already so beautiful
thank you but wow gosh
darn it god you're so good all right be
sure to check out
the wessman atelier collection we're
going to be featuring
on our website i suggest you get the
whole line because you can do your whole
face with it
um and pick up the new squeaky clean
liquid lip balm and collette i am going
to send you home
with the whole line so you don't have to
worry how am i going to do this and get
this it's all been taken care of oh my
goodness
thank you thank you well then good we're
done
you